Houston received record amounts of
rainfall after hurricane Harvey slammed
ashore the flood water stranded many
people our Houston affiliate KH oh you
broadcast one rescue live as it unfolded
last month reporter Brandon Smith led
first responders to a stranded
semi-truck driver on a flooded Road she
tracked that driver down today to see
how he's doing brandy Smith joins us now
to share the reunion brandy it's so good
to have you here it's wonderful to be
here thank you so much for having me
Robert was in kind of a tough spot when
we first saw him he was stuck in the cab
of his truck with nowhere to go as water
rose around him we just happened to be
standing on an overpass above and a
rescue crew just happened to drive by
moments later it was a chance encounter
that Roberson believes was the work of
God I could not imagine how terrifying
it would be to be stuck right there
right now you can probably hear in my
voice the helplessness we felt as
videographer marios and of all and i
broadcast from an overpass in northern
houston i'm trying to get reconnected
really quickly communications were
difficult as remnants of hurricane
harvey swamped our city you're hearing
from folks back at the station and we
had just gotten word that we were alone
on the air water was gushing into our
station prompting staff to head for
higher ground
I think he's hanging on the edge of the
window so as we peered into that cab
with a man trapped inside there was
little we could do I'm gonna flag these
guys down that's when we spotted a
rescue team from the Harris County
Sheriff's Office there's a truck driver
stuck here in about ten feet of water
how high did the water get the water go
just where you're seeing it on the owner
on the picture right there at the window
the driver inside that truck was Robert
Roberson we caught up with him at home
with his wife in Mississippi he says he
didn't realize the water was that high
until it was too late they actually go
in that water instead of hitting your
chest you stuff what feeling like you
getting short of breath as he caught his
breath his first priority he's
says was finding his water-resistant
phone which had sunk in his cab he
wanted to speak to his wife Virginia
yeah I called her and I'd say look you
know you know something going on here
pray for me he said that my truck been
floored you know the war don't took over
the truck he said don't tell me then you
know that something he said and the
television camera was rolling as
rescuers entered the water will you how
that law save me and here he goes we
could barely contain our relief as
emergency responders delivered Roberson
to safety
we don't know how what kind of pressure
or human being can really take we really
just don't know until you live it I'll
tell you David can I get there were more
hugs back at home where Robert Roberson
is getting back to work in a replacement
truck each of us grateful we came across
the other when we did my god thank you
Roberson tells us he spent several days
at the George R Brown Convention Center
there's a shelter there before his
company picked him up and provided him
with that replacement truck he tells me
he still has dreams about the rising
water but he tries not to think about
what would have happened if help hadn't
come along when it did well brandy boy
we watched that you know live on TV when
it happened cuz we were broadcasting a
lot of your coverage and then it went
viral I mean the reaction I'm sure you
got from what from from that story it's
been a little bit surreal and really I
think a large part of why it went viral
was our signal for KHOU cut out so as I
had flagged down the truck with the
airboat our signal died and a lot of
people were left on the audience
wondering yes whether he made it out
okay Mario the photographer I was
working with had the wherewithal to have
been rolling the entire time so we were
able to post that video on Facebook if
he if Mario hadn't done that then this
wouldn't have yeah thank you Mario but
the way I think what touched everybody
about you brandy said it was so
spontaneous and so human and I'm
wondering what you were thinking during
that moment because I could barely see
that guy in fact I couldn't see the guy
in the truck yeah clearly you could what
were you thinking during that time I'd
love to say I was thinking I don't know
that I was I just went into autopilot I
had this job to do as a reporter I knew
I was the lone reporter left live for
our station because they had evacuated
it had flooded and I knew we had to get
this guy out of the truck so I tried to
figure out a way to do it simultaneously
thank goodness he said he asked his wife
to pray for him did he think he was
going to die actually he said he wasn't
scared the prayers came earlier when he
knew
the forecast was pretty messy for
Houston but at the moment the money
let's just say this about brandy you've
only been on the job six months at that
station put that on your resume remark
boss's name is Ryan K Joe you should
call yeah and by the way and by the way
when I got back watching the DVS this
morning we'll be right back